[Música]
hablamos de economía aquí en directo
América nos acompaña en el estudio Jorge
Hurtado Jorge bienvenido lo anunciamos
en El Avance que Perú allí la gripe
aviar está afectando la producción de
pollo y de los productores avícolas y
prevén una crisis que se va a mantener
por lo menos Más allá del mes de abril
Qué es lo que está pasando bueno
Santiago debido a la escasez los precios
seguirán al alza afectando sobre todo
los bolsillos de los peruanos que llevan
meses batallando con la inflación
avivada por factores externos pero
también por esa inestabilidad interna
nuestro corresponsal en Lima Francisco
Zacarías recorrió algunos comercios y
nos amplía la información en este
reportaje
la gripe aviar obligó a los avicultores
peruanos a eliminar más de 850.000
gallinas en las últimas semanas
alrededor de 15 millones de pollos
dejaron de nacer en un mes para el
productor Avícola y representante de
avisur Alex geri las pérdidas han sido
millonarias con la cantidad que se
eliminó han perdido entre 12 y 13
millones de dólares solamente en costo
de inversión sin contar la parte que tú
la producción que la estás no la vas a
tener eso también es un ingreso que no
va a producir para afrontar la
emergencia sanitaria que ha bajado de la
producción de pollos en un 25%, el
gobierno anunció la importación de 17
millones de huevos férriles para ser
criados en las granjas
una de las consecuencias el volumen de
pollo comercializado hoy es 7,2% menor
que el de hace un año Rosa Miranda ama
de casa Comenta que la Alimentación en
su hogar ha cambiado ya no es igual No
ya ya no Uno no puede ya dar las
porciones como dabas No ya ya es menos
ya las porciones
el kilo de pollo en los mercados de Lima
y su área metropolitana promedia los
3,37 dólares 35% más caro que un año
atrás la inflación en Perú fue del 9%
anual en febrero con los alimentos
subiendo el doble impulsados por el
precio del ave
los restaurantes que venden pollo a la
brasa típica comida de los peruanos
también notan el sobrecosto y con eso
como siempre va a bajar porque ya el
precio no es muy accesible Y
lamentablemente tenemos que pasar esta
situación al afrontarlo porque no
sabemos qué va a pasar pues porque si se
sigue al alza varios negocios se van a
quebrar ese es el problema
los peruanos esperan que las autoridades
avancen con la vacunación de pollos y
solucionen la escasez y el alza del
precio Pero los avicultores advierten
que el proceso será lento
de Perú nos vamos hasta Ecuador porque
la petrolera estatal de ese país declaró
el cierre de varios bloques de
explotación en la región de la amazonía
por los conflictos que hay en la zona
cuéntenos Jorge Bueno desde hace varios
meses las comunidades de la zona
mantienen bloqueos que impiden el normal
desarrollo de las actividades
hidrocarburíferas petroecuador dijo que
el bloque 12 de en YouTube y ubicado en
la zona del conflicto extra bajo la
declaración de fuerza mayor desde el 16
de marzo al que ahora se suman otros
tres nuevos bloques al declarar fuerza
mayor la estatal se blinda de eventuales
demandas por incumplimiento de los
compromisos de venta y exportación de
crudo ante eventos adversos que escapan
de su control el petróleo es uno de los
principales productos de exportación de
Ecuador así como una de las fuentes más
importantes de ingreso para el gobierno
porque pasamos ahora a hablar de Estados
Unidos porque habló la secretaría del
tesoro este remesón que hay en el
sistema bancario bueno según ella el
sector se está estabilizando después de
que las recientes quiebras de silicon y
sacudieron a la industria quieren
aseguró que Estados Unidos está
preparado para intervenir más de ser
necesario señalando que podrían
justificarse acciones similares y bancos
más pequeños sufren retiros masivos como
lo ocurrido con nosotros bancos que
escuchamos
las medidas que optamos no se centraron
en ayudar a bancos o clases de bancos
concretos nuestra intervención era
necesaria para proteger el sistema
bancario estadounidense en general y
acciones similares podrían estar
justificadas si instituciones más
pequeñas sufren retiradas de depósitos
que supongan un riesgo de contagio
Jorge terminamos hablando de
Inteligencia artificial porque Bill
Gates el cofundador de Microsoft dijo
que el chat gpt es un avance
completamente revolucionario qué más
dijo Bueno esta Inteligencia artificial
desarrollada por openia es una de las
dos innovaciones tecnológicas más
significativas que él ha visto la
primera según él es la interfaz gráfica
de usuario esta que permite la
interacción entre los humanos y las
computadoras por medio de iconos
ventanas y menús Open y ahí la creadora
de este chat gpt tiene un respaldo de 10
mil millones de dólares de parte de
Microsoft y recientemente lanzó gpt 4
una versión más avanzada del modelo
masivo que genera texto de forma
Autónoma Jorge muchas gracias por esta
actualización del mundo de la economía
es todo por el momento aquí en el bloque
informativo a continuación en directo
América el debate
[Música]